ha ha this hi my name is Yoli and I've
been a professional chef for about 15
years
hi my name is Diana and I have been
cooking professionally for 8 years and
today we are going to try to make these
frozen dinners look fancy I always
wanted to do Iron Chef I'd say this is
pretty close yeah this is pretty close
and I just see piles of mush in
different colors also there's not a lot
of good so we knew what we were gonna be
working with so we brought some stuff
with us we brought the color the fine
dining touches and for the reveal this
doesn't look like oh the way there are
oh my it's your nose now we get options
on ourselves very say you know I'm not
gonna wait for you
[Music]
all right I want to start but I don't
know what doesn't boil is July I hope
whoever eats this actually puts on a
play and doesn't get off these plastic
things so really sad I'm going to slice
it as if it is a steak just go with it
I'm gonna lean it into appetizer portion
step 1 mm-hmm
this is fish hmm yep it's like a big
fish stick that comes with rice
broccoli mush and I'm I am not even sure
what this is when I liked how this one
looked but that one actually has a
rating that I'm not done
I brought a skewer so I'm gonna use it
hey are you like where you're going with
that I'm trying not to support you but
it's kind of hard hmm
got an appetizer huh oh this broccoli is
rough don't make this you don't mix an
old
it's like turns into cement you know
what there's so much liquid in that I'm
just gonna call it a soup this has a
crapload of water in it I'm guessing
because it was frozen I'm almost done
with my appetizer good for you this is a
very small soup because it didn't have
as much liquid as I thought it did but
it's okay that's done okay rice
my grow greens help everything look
fancy I know throw some of these things
on anything
yeah I'm people are gonna be like what
is that so fancy I want I want my
appetizer I am done with this as well
all right entree I got to put like color
on this state because the steak looks
rough I'm definitely staying away from
that
spongebob macaroni spongebob was a chef
he never called off never called off I'm
trying to make good different shapes
always help all right
oh I just turned this into a palm puree
mm-hmm those marks that's a steak let's
just pretend close our eyes and pretend
it's medium-rare had some color to it
mushroom get mushrooms red you've got
mushroom so there's like two floating in
the hungry man I'm gonna do this we're
gonna pretend like this is like some
risotto look at that color
look at this you know what you're
working with right I feel like you're
forgetting for a moment everything here
[Music]
that's gross you know what maybe we want
to go for like a surf and turf kind of
situation such a good idea
[Music]
cover this people eat with their eyes
first so if the food comes out and it
doesn't look that appetizing you already
go in there with the mentality of this
is I'm gonna be that good yeah look good
people already have a preconceived
notion of what the food is gonna look
like before it even gets to their plate
all right pretend like this is gravy
which is not but why don't they put a
lemon in here they can't put a lemon
wedge with the fish yeah like the lemon
will hold up everyone has these at home
you could just use your garden and just
spruce up your meal it's a flower
I believe it's an amorous the flowers
are chefs watching all right I want to
go to crazy I'm gonna call that done
[Music]
are you molding I wanted to pretend like
he's this was ice cream is that cheating
yes
judges huh yeah it has to be edible or
just look I'm gonna I'm gonna scoop this
delicious vanilla ice cream what is this
what gonna do that people are gonna
think that it's ice cream
oh my god is that ice cream yes vanilla
nobody hater hater chef boss I'm gonna
use all the spoons so then you have to
use steak sauce covers why is this
I lost a piece of printed only dessert
that comes in these meals you need any
crumbs no I'm just gonna use the liquid
oh there's a piece of broccoli give it a
nice little glaze carry on carry on I'm
trying to be creative not just look like
a Bon Appetit catalog why you're killing
it now they're gonna cancel my
subscription to that that's gone that's
always fun all right
you want to let some of the sand go on
to play like if it's intentional little
expands dear when I'm looking at these
flowers I'm looking just for color
something that is gonna make the desert
more vibrant and just they're all edible
so you can definitely like eat all the
flowers that and the garnishes that we
put on there which that's always fun
like you know somewhere playful
I mean I had a couple of panic attacks
while trying to do this for sure it was
fun it was fun I mean I suggest
everybody placed their frozen meals from
now on because there's no way you cannot
eat them out of that box
yeah the box makes it sad yeah if you if
you put on a plate get wild with it
yeah kill your glass put it in the
freezer put the ice cream on there
pair it with a nice little rose a or a
white wine
take a couple flowers from your garden
and just sprinkle it on top
[Music]